how does the financing Behind movies
work each movie is different and I've
been a part of almost every category you
know I I think if
you're if your business is to be in the
studio
system then you're going to put your
concentration on on if you're a writer
you know if you're a writer director
filmmaker you're going to put your
concentration on writing something that
is going to get you into that system or
directing a short that's going to get
you into that system where the financing
is coming from a
studio
and and that it's you know it's with
that comes more restrictions you know
you're dealing with many more layers of
of Gatekeepers and and things like that
but I've always loved that process I
mean I
started um with Clive's company I
started in that system in the studio
system and setting up projects at Studio
iOS and you know you're kind of really
honing that screenplay to fit the budget
if it's in the millions you know if
you're
doing a project that's in the millions
and you're like
okay the the funny thing that I found is
that doing a project that is
multi-millions of
dollars or hundreds of thousands of
dollars it never feels different in the
process of making the movie you're
always hit with the same constraints in
a way uh and you just adjust to it it's
weird how you think it would feel
drastically different but it it doesn't
to me now the other ways like with Scott
when we worked the films we did uh in
Florida those were financed with private
Equity so Scott put the the manh hours
in to cultivate relationships with
uh people not in the film business you
know because there's a lot of people in
in in the world that have
money and they're in finance or business
and they you know making movies as sexy
it's it's it's an adventure or it's you
know they'll have like I'll come to set
and I'll be part of this process and and
also a lot of people don't need to make
their money back you know so a lot of
financing is a write-off to their other
business
so
film you know makes sense to them they
can put a lot of equ in something and
they don't need a payout right away it's
something that builds over time and so
that's one way to do it you know you and
now now with things like Kickstarter and
you know Indie goo you know people are
self- financing with crowdfunding which
is something that I have not done
personally but know a lot of people that
have there's basically there's a lot of
ways to fund a picture right now and
I've kind of been part of most of
them I think one of the the most
pragmatic ways
is is you you're dissecting the movie
and its components you're bringing in
relationship
financiers that are
selling overseas right they're going to
the film markets like AFM and Berlin and
they're taking your poster and they're
taking your concept and they're
pre-selling Market markets or they're
raising it based on an actor you may
have in the film and they're saying okay
we can you know we can give you half a
million dollars to go shoot this
movie so there's just so many different
ways you can fund a movie
now that there is no one way
really what are your thoughts on putting
your own money into your movies I think
if you're doing a short then yes like I
I think you know if you
can if you can raise money yourself you
can use your own Equity you
can have family give you funds then for
sure because that's an investment in
your career you should try to get as
much as you can to make that best short
as possible because that's going to be
your calling card and it can it can
launch your whole career so I think
that's if you're doing a feature I would
never recommend it like I don't I don't
think making an independent feature
is going to return your investment you
know I think that's a dangerous thing to
do um
Because unless you're winning
Sundance there's not a lot of people
that get big opportunities for making
features I like something you learn when
you go to can is
that you walk through that Marketplace
and you realize okay there are thousands
of movies being made every year that
never see the light of day and here they
are at this Marketplace I always thought
that was really fascinating that it was
like okay there's a and it makes you it
makes you also kind of reinforces what
you're doing in a sense of
like okay you're making movies that are
getting seen by audiences and getting
good distribution thing that's that's
hard you know for like never anyone who
gets their movie out there like never
disparage that like oh I wish more
people saw it like if you get
distribution you've you've
won a huge part of that cuz so many
movies don't so I would never say and
you know put your own money into a
feature you say that someone who gets
distribution they're already sort of
miles ahead but what if that movie
doesn't make a penny back what if they
see nothing from their distributor are
they still should they still say hey
look I've I've accomplished something
well yeah because it's a stepping stone
to their career I you know I think an
indie film
making M the movie making
money is going to be a long road you
know for the most part so I don't think
anyone should get disparaged by also
Distributors are always going to be a
big Cy about how much the movie's really
making and you know when you see it
reporting and you know it's not it's not
cut and
dry um and it's very technical and and I
think most people don't expect their
movies to make money right away so if
someone's Distributing your movie they
have a 5year plan you know they have a 5
to 15-e plan you know they know that
this is going to make this much money by
year nine or 10 and that's part of their
business so I don't think people should
ever get caught up on the money and how
much money it makes you should get
caught up on does it open doors for you
you know are the right people seeing it
at
festivals can you get into the right
people's hands cuz you're always going
to have to take control of that just to
some extent and not not just expect
people to like knock on your door like
hey you want to make a movie you just
made this movie you want to make another
will you begin filming before you have
your entire budget in
place I've never done that but I know
filmmakers that have and they film when
they can you know they may be shooting
only on the weekends or they'll shoot as
much and that's a you can do it you can
then you can put a real together if if
you're shooting you put re together and
try to get more financing so if you're
really confident about your idea and
about your vision for it then that it's
a a way to do it you if you get if you
can get a teaser together and then bring
that to financiers or Distributors you
could raise the other funds or other
Talent getting other Talent involved
it's a good way to do it have you been
to many film markets you said you walked
through con and you saw all these titles
I mean I'll I'll when especially when I
was with Clyde we'd go to the film
markets a lot and we'd see the movies
there we'd watch the new like because we
were always looking for writers and
directors to adapt Clive's stuff and and
so we could set up his project so we
would go to the markets a lot and watch
movies
and you know off you know with a film I
don't usually go with a film like the
film may go I don't often travel with it
but sometimes we will just to kind of be
a part of it or if we're having a
screening there and we can afford to
send us all we'll go what's the best
lesson you can teach us about movie
financing I think as you know it changes
on a yearly basis and I think if
it's I think if you're a filmmaker that
wants to get a feature made and I think
it's always going to be
challenging to raise that Equity
yourself I think
right now is a good time to really hone
your concept make sure you you have a a
concept that not only is personal to you
but is something that other people are
going to want to get excited about so
you're bringing something fresh and new
and I feel right now is the time to make
shorts that's my opinion that's what I'm
seeing in the market there's a lot of
short content going around again it was
like that in the mid 2000s I feel like
it's like that again a lot of filmmakers
are getting
getting opportunities based on their
shorts their short stories even not even
short films but short
stories um so if you can put a chunk of
change in a short and make it look like
a feature you make it look as
sophisticated as you
can and also make sure it's a proof of
concept that someone can be like I could
turn this into a
movie I
I can't say that enough that if you're
making a short just because you think
it's a a cute short or a good
story and but if if if you just want to
make short films and that's your thing
then by all means but if you want to be
shooting features and you're going to
spend all that effort and money and time
on a short make sure it's a proof of
concept for a larger idea something that
someone can be like oh this would make a
great film this is a great idea I can
see this has legs for a
feature I think that's the really the
way to do it cuz then the financing will
find
you what about financing in a down
economy you know you talked about you
know mid 2000s okay well 2005 versus
2008 is going to have a lot different
opportunity um not sure where we are in
the economy currently but it seems like
it might be tougher I think it's on the
sizes too I think if you're you know
when Scott was raising
money and he's doing it in a state he
was doing it in Florida where you know
he he had made contacts with people that
were wealthy I think at at one end a
down economy only hurts certain classes
you know people who have money are still
going to have money they they're not
affected by the economy in the same way
others are and movies are always been
known to be resilient in in recession so
I think I think it's approaching it the
same way but if if again if it's if
you're making a short you have a lot of
options at your disposal the race funds
if you're doing a crowdfunding or
something like that because you can make
a short you C you can make a good
short for $1,000 I mean you can make a a
great short for
$30,000 you know
um
so in that
realm if you can raise $1,000 to make a
short just make sure you're telling the
right short for $ 30,000 I just watched
a short the other day that was very
contained almost no lighting but it was
a great concept and I could see that oh
this would make a great movie so it was
two rooms but it was enough to and it
also got picked up by a studio so so it
works if you can find the right idea you
don't need a ton of financing to do
it